servus skates und herzlich willkommen zu
einer kit vorstellung es gibt neue kids
länder games und nichts habe ich heute
dass koerfer
so das war das intro bevor es losging
mit der runde lese ich euch noch kurz
die beschreibung vor von dem kit die
lautet mord vor dem mauerfall nimmt mit
jedem kitty fähigkeit fehlt die
fähigkeit des kit seines gegners ein und
startet mit einer rüstung sowie wegen
des kit optimal aus das heißt wenn wir
sterben
nein nicht wenn wir sterben wir kennen
wenn wir einen delfin killen können wir
auf einem im wasserspringen wenn kinder
kennen sie mir an meinem land die
krassesten wenn wir in bombay killen
können wir tiere und menschen töten so
dass sie explodieren richtig krasse
action oder wenn die vampir sinnt
das hatte ich grad eben auch schon dann
kriegen wir zum beispiel für getötete ob
drei herzen und für einen getöteten
spieler volle herzen regeneration dann
ja das ist eigentlich ziemlich geile
sache und ich habe mir das neue kit
vorstellen sei nicht einfach die runde
hoch so wie ich spiele wenn ich früh
sterben möchte das so dann liegt es
vielleicht an geht ich würde sagen einer
games kann ich eigentlich schon halbwegs
spieler auch schon relativ lange
und ja ich würd sagen wenn ich früh
sterben ist es vielleicht ein zeichen
dafür dass das kind nicht so doll ist
wie die anderen kids mit denen zum
beispiel der beispielsweise bombe und ja
deswegen würde ich sagen statt sich
einfach an
wenn ihr bock auf mehr von diesem vorort
vorstellung habt dann lasst jetzt schon
mal einen kommentar da und ein like
damit immer das zeigen könnt und dann
will ich auf jeden fall machen wenn ihr
bock drauf habt kann sich vorstellen die
neu dazu gekommen sind wenn ihr wollt
und da würde ich sagen
let the games begin so liegt vor dir
alles klar
ja ihr seht hier beim zwei gelbe
rüstungsteile alle tabus und leider
tuning das macht zwar ein
rüstungsprojekte aus die meisten fall
hat sage ich ganz cool und holen uns
jetzt erstmal die sachen in dem sie
kräften
es gibt bin ich hallo was geht ach leute
ich habe es fast vergessen ich habe es
echt fast vergessen auch die hundezone
weg mit dir ich habe es echt fast
vergessen
wir haben ja die 4k geknallt ist geil
ich habe ich darauf gewartet dass wir es
schaffen so dicht als allererstes hier
soll man lieber sorry aber du hast du
dir verdient damit dass minecraft gebaut
hast so richtig krass 24 hier
fucking k protesten bomber ziemlich
offensichtlich was wird er machen ist
eine einer wüsten einfach keine tiere
gut hätten so gravity wird doch über den
betten
ich will auch mal sein gepäck ihr wisst
ja das kind hat den effekt dass man die
fähigkeit des anderen übernehmen weil
man jetzt stand bekommen sterben
ach was ich hab da stehst da unten steht
leute ihr könnt sehen
ich hab es geht bomber bekommen und
direkten leuten den typ damit gekippt
online keno alte war es knapp richtig
hart ich sterbe junge war das knapp
jetzt lass mir erst mal ruhig mal regen
mal lieber nein bitte nicht bittet mich
nicht bitten ich bitte das weiß ich zu
kraus ich beschwere mich bei meinen
eltern straight
ach komm jetzt bitte ab aber ich bin
jetzt letzte letzter escape was anna
nein ich hab's verdeckt werden wir die
klassen wie der switch zu der klasse die
wir bekommen um als wir den anderen
getötet haben ok 24 wir sind bei 426 wie
macher von kurzen cut spielen die
nächste runde noch mal die rolle wird
genauso direkt hochkommen um euch
einfach zu zeigen wie es wirklich ist
mit dem pc spiel jetzt habt ihr so ein
bisschen gesehen was da geht
und sorry aufnahme wir können nicht
trocken ja wie gehabt an die nächste
runde sehen uns dann gleich wieder
österreich und so dass er wieder runde
nummer zwei mit dem moor verkehrt und
ich würde sagen genau wie in der ersten
runde zeige ich einfach mal wie es ist
es geht so zog mich kann man schon so
viel sagen es ist nicht so leicht also
ich bin doch noch eine ecke schlechter
als mit känguru oder bombe vielleicht
ist auch gewöhnungssache wir starten auf
jeden fall mal und gucke mir drin ist
nicht so toll nein nicht total
wisst ihr bescheid
die dauer reisen und über die das
obgleich aber wir brauchen ein bisschen
mehr
okay da um als sehr gut agent benny
dieser crazy motherfucker welches geht
ist das mit der gärten musste ja sagt
sie meine oder so ich sagen abgesehen
rüstung ist immer noch die gleiche wie
kraft ist schön ein tier schwer macht
jetzt keinen sinn aus dem eisen was zu
machen weil wir eigentlich schon schuhe
haben da warten wir bis wir dann noch
ein eisen haben so und uns dann ein
einen helm machen können würde ich sagen
bis dahin warten wir und gucken einfach
mal wie weit wir in dieser runde kommen
wir versuchen unsere glück wir haben auf
jeden fall schonmal nahrung
wir haben die ofenkartoffeln das ist
ziemlich gut dann müssen wir nicht ewig
suchen
ok diesen satz ziemlich weit hinten da
kann man jeden fall nicht so kopper
anschleichen alles gefehlt
oli jou ein bomber würdigt bombe
allerdings töten können
dann sind auch bommer und wären die
skipper bekommen sehr gut sehr gut sehr
sehr gut
als sie abgesehen mal übernimmt das kit
da unten steht seit der leiste gibt
gesehen falls nicht könnte man
zurückspulen steht du hast das kay
bommer bekommen und ja so läuft das in
der hut man kriegt noch eine
benachrichtigung von ender games also
von dem server in dem star drin steht
und dann hat man das geht ja so ist das
alles klar wir haben immer noch nicht
genug schüssel wir können es eigentlich
könnte es einen theoretischen ddr machen
da kann man es immerhin mal kein
bogenschützen headshots kerl ist es
nicht so dass beste aber jo stück für
stück
ja schade leute so geht's man stirbt
doch einfach mal und wie gesagt ich habe
sie versprochen ist klar keine
krassesten aber für der elf mal zeigen
wie es ist mit dem kind zu spielen
ich würde sagen es ganz gut
durchgekommen hat gesehen aber übernimmt
die fähigkeiten und ja also es ist
sicher ein ganz interessantes kit man
brauche auf jeden fall einiges
angewöhnungszeit bei mir aber ist jetzt
nicht zu schnell gegangen
die kids sind zwar noch nicht so lange
draußen das müsste mir auch zu gute
halten
aber ja ich würde sagen es ist auf jeden
fall etwas mal ganz interessant ist weil
man einfach die rollen switch ihr wisst
ihr bescheid
man ist eine bombe und mal delfin und
das hat natürlich ein
überraschungseffekt wenn man sich
zweimal trifft im spiel und beim
einigung oder bestellt weil zwar erstmal
eine bombe bombe getötet hat das kann
durchaus vorteile bringen
und ich würde sagen ja es ist ein ganz
interessantes geht es wahrscheinlich
nicht so meins probiert auf jeden fall
mal aus wenn ihr die konzepte würde ich
sagen
haut rein macht es gut und wenn es
wieder gefallen hat hütet den like
-button auf jeden fall ich das mikro
hätten so wie ich einem scharfen
kommentar lasst mich wissen ob ich noch
mehr folgen davon machen soll
und natürlich sagen sie uns beim
nächsten video wieder macht's gut und
ciao